and we have a heads up now on big time
long-term road work this is going on up
in nye county on u.s 95 so starting a
week from today the nevada department of
transportation is going to have eight
months worth of a rolling one lane
closure on the 95 between amargosa
valley and baity it's pretty big deal
ndot's going to be using flaggers and a
pilot car to get you through it is more
than a repaving project crews are not
only widening the lanes on that 28-mile
stretch but they're also going to be
putting in a couple of areas of passing
lanes so that would be helpful uh
scheduled to start april 11th again
that's a week from today maybe running
through the end of the year i wanted to
give you a week long heads up and i'm
going to remind you next monday as well
a couple of other improvements planned
for the work area got a map we have
specific mile markers for all of this in
the online version of this story at
8newsnow.com when you click traffic then
driving you crazy buckle up drive
carefully please put down that phone
something's driving you crazy email me
traffic eight at eightnewsnow.com